tout au long de l'été l'été de nos 20
ans nous allons vous présenter des
reportages tirer de nos archives c'est
le cas de celui ci où on rencontre
pierre mittelette un gars qui a du pif
vous sentez bien ce que les femmes et
les yeux mais nous est en mon pouvoir
voilà l'assiette de blaye des
croustilles déceler les saveurs
aromatiques qui n'a rien de bien sorcier
pour pierre miclette ça goûte un peu
barbecue et que oui
et
un autre un peu
il ya le pi niort ce diplômé en
biotechnologie est un créateur de
parfums qui se mange c'est un arôme à
titien l'aromatique parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on appelle notre industrie
avec un des buts est l'art de
l'industrialisation des produits
alimentaires donc on a commencé à
chauffer énormément pasteurisé les
produits donc on arrivait avec des
produits de qualité gustative en tout
cas très très inférieurs et on a fait
appel à des parfumeurs dans le temps
parce que les armes at il n'existait pas
chez mais tu as rome neotec on a créé en
cinq ans près de 5000 havre ont donc
voici
aromatiques
dans chacun cela on peut trouver la robe
que ce soit
ben
[Musique]
fromage jasmin
et au final ça va sentir goûter quoi ça
l'est plus et
c'est combien produits que vous avez
mélanger pour faire un petit blanc nez
avec une douzaine
comment on avait déjà fabriqué la bombe
de quelque chose puisque ces composés de
plusieurs molécules ce qu'on arrive à
faire c'est évidemment isoler les
molécules les plus importantes qui amène
le goût donc si je vous parle d'une
orange je vais vous parler de delta
limonène de canal au canal hd canal
octane sommes donc là vous me regarde
avec des grandes urbain oui c'est ce
qu'on marche dans ce sondage question
ici m'a fait je vous ai amené quelques
descripteur pour faire une offre en
bouche la beauté tout ça c'est que si je
vous les donne séparément ça fait pas
une revanche mais quand je vais vous les
donnez tous ensemble ça va faire une
revanche ah ouais ouais non alors on
pourrait comparer avec une vraie orange
pour voir la complexité
c'est là sa meilleure
[Rires]
amie lui le talent que vous avez c'est
inné et
surtout à qui sait la passion puis c'est
vraiment travailler la mémoire olfactive
qui est très très importante mais moi
j'ai toujours dit que même si
si une photo vaut mille mots ben non
roms une odeur va vous rappeler 1000
photos souvent ça vous ramène à votre
enfant ça vous ramener à des choses que
vous avez complètement oublié ouais
vraiment les pommes griller dans du
beurre avec de la vanille
en dessert
ça rappelle les repas la maison c'est au
tour de table avec des blagues enfin
elle en pense
qu'avec important de la sauce reggae si
on parle vraiment de ma jeunesse mon
repas et qui faisait une bonne sauce
spaghetti à tarbes
moyen des scripteurs en trop que quand
je le sens je pense à ma grand mère
quant à m'embrasser c'est sûr que ça
sentait sans que j'aie gt r j'avais la
tête enfouie en titre de gros seins mais
sait-on que je sentais c'était le talent
que j'avais quelques quelques émettez
des jeunes et la côte-nord quand je suis
devant lui seul tout ça sent la mer
l'eau salée ça ça me rappelle ma
jeunesse on goûte avec quoi groupe oui
on goûte avec notre notre langue notre
bouche parce que c'est notre langue sur
notre bouchon de plaine récepteur sucré
salé acide et amer en fait on goûte
beaucoup plus pardonné que par notre
bouche et quand on met un aliment dans
notre bouche c'est un plus si on le
mettait dans un petit four à crème
glacée et à
3° peut-être moins d'eux mêmes vous
mettez ça 37 évidemment ça prend pas
autant que le gros font que les sucres
fondre et que les volatiles de la
vanille ou depuis rapporte le parfum
vous avez prix commencent à remonter par
rétro olfaction jusqu'à votre bulbe
olfactif et c'est là où des centaines de
molécules sont identifiés que vous votre
cerveau identifié comme étant vannerie
pour apprécier toute la complexité des
arômes suffit comme un musicien de
s'entraîner un peu allez-y fermer les
yeux humer goûter et redécouvrez votre
nez
[Musique]